There are many theories that attempt to quantify...
...the number of hours, days and even years of practice...
...that it takes to master a skill.
While we don't yet have a magic number,...
...we do know that mastery isn't simply about the amount of hours of practice.
It's also the quality and effectiveness of that practice.
Effective practice is consistent, intensely focused,...
...and targets content or weaknesses that lie at the edge of one's current abilities.
So, if effective practice is the key,...
...how can we get the most out of our practice time?
Try these tips.
Focus on the task at hand.
Minimize potential distractions by turning off the computer or TV...
...and putting your cellphone on airplane mode.
Start out slowly or in slow motion.
Coordination is built with repetitions, whether correct or incorrect.